hey everybody jesse here and today we're
going to be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the latest
game from tango gameworks ghostwire
tokyo ghostware looks to be as if doctor
strange met dying light or control and
i'm honestly really excited to see what
it can bring to the table with its
unique style and look so let's dive in
[Music]
ghostwire tokyo is a new ip from the
evil within studio tango gameworks
however unlike the third person survival
horror of those games ghostwire tokyo is
something we rarely see a japanese
developed first-person shooter the game
places you into the shoes of a young
student in tokyo named atiku izuki who
wakes up after being hit by a car and
dying so we're starting off all yu
hakushon with this story because
afterwards izuku is saved by kk not the
singing dog from animal crossing but a
mysterious spirit who merges with izuki
allah shadow of mordor giving izuki new
supernatural abilities and this
ultimately proves to be incredibly
helpful given that nearly all of tokyo's
residents have mysteriously disappeared
and dark spirits now roam the streets
looking to take down anyone who might
still be left izuki begins to explore
the transformed city streets in order to
save his kidnapped sister from a strange
man wearing a hinaya mask for which kk
also wants revenge against for some
unknown reasons putting our two heroes
goals into alignment the two set out to
uncover the mysteries surrounding the
happenings in tokyo as well as learn
more about kk's mysterious backstory and
the strange figure in the mask after a
short opening segment the game allows
you to explore the open world
environment of the japanese city now
filled with monsters straight out of
japanese horror or scp-style stories you
got your slendermans your headless
schoolgirls your whatever the hell this
thing is the tokyo of ghostwire seems to
be beautifully rendered as well and
grounds you in its more otherworldly
elements as you set out to rescue your
sister however what's most important
about this game's world is that you can
feed the doggies walking around the city
already it's the best game ever like
many open world games you'll be able to
explore the city while trying to avoid
the mysterious creatures however to
unlock new areas of the map you'll have
to cleanse the spirits from tory gates
surrounding the city which will allow
you to continue your exploration while
you'll be able to head straight through
the game's story much of the exploration
of the game's world will come through
side quests with some of the more
friendly creepy new denizens of tokyo
asking for your help with various
problems one mission for example will
have you find a personal item for a
spirit in order to help them pass on to
the next life while our gameplay preview
writer richard wakeling did find some of
these side quests to be lacking in his
initial few hours of the game he did
also find some of the ways the game
explored japanese folklore to be
intriguing even further you can stock up
on your items at convenience stores run
by talking kitties again 10 out of 10 no
notes dotted around the map and you'll
also be able to find different buffs and
collectibles as you continue to explore
so all in all this is fairly standard
ubisoft style open world design albeit
with a japanese horror flair
similarly though physical movement in
ghost wire tokyo draws comparison to
another open world horror game that was
released earlier this year dying light
too indeed the tango ability will allow
izuki to swing around buildings
throughout the map by grappling to
flying monsters which will also be
paired with the game's gliding mechanic
however the game hopes to not only stand
out through its unique world but in its
combat as well after the game's
announcement publisher bethesda stated
quote the combat team at tango have
created an intricate combo-based system
that utilizes movements inspired by
traditional kujikiri hand gestures the
combat was in part crafted by sincharo
hari who was one of the driving forces
on doom 2016's excellent almost
rhythm-like violent gameplay setting a
high bar and legacy for ghostwire tokyo
to follow up on despite being modeled
after first-person shooters though uzuki
doesn't use guns but instead wields his
newfound super of natural abilities
through ethereal weaving which he
channels through various finger
movements in a way stylistically akin to
doctor strange like a sort of
supernatural avatar the last airbender
weaving allows you to channel different
elements like wind fire or water wind
weaving feels more defensive allowing
you to push enemies away and knock them
around but also charge it up for
potential instant kills fire is much
more damaging allowing you to shoot
explosive balls of damage towards your
enemies but is much more costly and how
much ammunition it takes up water
meanwhile works best for close quarters
combat allowing you to hit enemies
quickly and hard the game also has
defensive abilities allowing you to
negate damage and even parry to prevent
any damage done to you the developers
themselves equated this combat system to
karate meeting magic mixing movement
with style additionally your enemies
themselves will allow for a lot of
variety in gameplay certain enemies will
be more vulnerable to specific types of
damage will also expose their hearts
when attacked in the right way allowing
you to pull spiritual strings in order
to instantly take them down the combat
also features a skill tree that allows
you to unlock more abilities down the
line with many gameplay previews stating
that the combat really begins to unfold
and evolve once you begin to broaden
your skill set however this also means
that the initial hours of the game may
feel more limited as you're left with
fewer tools to handle your enemies
beyond the gameplay though as of right
now there has been no multiplayer or dlc
elements announced for the game meaning
that you're going to have to face the
horrors of tokyo all on your own
foreign as previously mentioned
ghostwire tokyo is being created by
tango gameworks a studio founded in 2010
by sinji mikami bakami is a towering
figure in video game history especially
within the horror genre he was the
director of the original resident evil
game and helped guide the series
development eventually directing and
helping wright the seminal resident evil
4. however after leaving capcom and
founding tango gameworks he eventually
created the evil within franchise that
seems to be more of a spiritual
successor to his work on resident evil
mixing third person survival horror
elements with a more surreal style story
and while ghostware tokyo seems to have
shifted gameplay genre tango gameworks
appears to be continuing to evolve its
style into the more ethereal less
grounded elements of horror within the
game while the evil within games
themselves are often considered to be
cult classics loved by devoted groups of
fans but never really reaching
mainstream appreciation we hope that the
new risks that ghostwire tokyo takes
with the tango gameworks formula will
help it reach a wider audience ghostwire
tokyo is set to launch on march 25th on
both playstation 5 and pc however the
game is supposedly a timed console
exclusive so xbox players will have to
wait a bit longer to jump into the
supernatural horror of tokyo streets
and that's all the basics you need to
know for the upcoming ghostwire tokyo
while it may be a big risk for the
studio it's exciting to see a new ip
trying to burst its way onto the
landscape especially one with such a
unique world and gameplay that will
hopefully pay off in the long run also i
just kind of want to buy it because you
can bet the dogs so you know i i have my
priorities straight if you want to know
more about ghostwire tokyo check out our
recently released preview of the game's
first two chapters so that you can be as
prepared as possible when the game
releases until then don't forget to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss all our coverage and forthcoming
review of ghostwire tokyo and everything
else we're doing here at gamespot
you